alright let's shift gears a little bit
here for 2 3 Forza horizon three sorry
has been announced Dave as you saw the
Lambo outside of microsoft's press
conference you spotted that yeah it was
that hot tip we saw the black and orange
would write the game as well so we did
we saw four people playing on a bunch of
different consoles on wheels on on
controllers on everything it's in
Australia look at us look at all this
Australia happening right now how much
Australia can you play a lot of it it's
an open world who's excited about this
one yeah Mike my hearty why you think
definitely i'm not really into racing
games but this looks like something that
i could just you just love Australia
yeah any game any movie Mad Max big fan
yeah yeah but mainly just the fact that
you can kind of almost lazily drive
around exploring right because i'm not
i'm not a competitive racer but my
favorite racing games are the ones that
like obviously they have that great like
kinetic energy to it but i'm looking
forward to actually kind of exploring
look at this you're racing a car that's
on a helicopter that's a bit unfair
really isn't alone oh it looks great
right like graphically I mean I mean I
racing I was mesmerized by this I I
thought it looked fantastic I thought
it's one of the best games on on on the
press conference I usually it reminds me
a little bit of Forza horizon it reminds
me a little bit oh yeah really the first
of all and also the second it reminds me
of burnout paradise like rice ok and i
miss burnout paradise daddy oh that's it
ok that's an interesting reference
because they are going for a four player
co-op open world my brain instantly went
to the crew which is because that was
basically the USP of that game was this
is a four player co-op game it's open
world go have a laugh for ya right
Brenner perros was the same thing mr.
jaunting around doing dumb types of
races and stuff ya doing crazy stuff in
beautiful location do you think DJ
atomica is in Forza horizon three I
would close I'd save what was your take
on this I it takes a lot for me to get
excited for a racing games right really
my thing but I am really excited to play
this the fact I can race through streets
swamps jungle beaches deserts yeah huge
variety of different like types of
racing like it's got like essence of
burnet pair
essence of dirt yes and some fort sir
it's kind of bringing all these
different essence of fuel yeah it's got
all the different racing games that have
brought them under one flag and sport
sir and it's just race anywhere I'm
really excited for it yeah it's actually
looks really diverse for a for
terrorizing game because actually you
know for a reason to it's very like okay
here's your Mediterranean and here is
your street but they can felt quite you
know Jim not generic just like across
the board pretty similar so yeah this
looks pretty interesting maybe not
allowed to run over the Kangaroos though
now that I won't allow it I wonder if
there's gonna be that one road that's
just like covered in cane toads know
like those truckers just one other
someone trucking race we just ruins your
handling burning through cane toads yeah
a drop a drop okay so sorry ed Tron is
directing the show's Australian he's
probably screaming in my ear right now
and coming to xbox one and windows 10
upgrade from millennium edition folks go
play for two rising 3